all right bonafide
hi mark welcome back thank you it's
great to see you again you look
fantastic
thank you i'm trying so what's what's
going on it's been it's been quite a
while since we were
together here well you know i mean since
the last video
where i said that i had wanted to be at
before august
the last of this year you know um
it's been a struggle i'm not quite sure
why it's been a struggle but
uh well no i don't want to say the word
but
99 of the time everything got there but
it's [ __ ]
you know it's been a hard year for
everybody though he'll teach you some
however since um since i came
last time
it i've had so many issues
so many uh it's beginning to get
discomforting to me
you know um if i had to really really
really really really look at the man
that's
just gonna stop for me on them streets
you know
uh
and some of the good ones are even bad
now you know
i had a man pull me over to the side of
the train track
he was old he was older you know what
i'm saying
you know half breathe or whatever
he pulled me over and he put out this
flashlight
it was like well i'm just going to tell
you what it is
you know uh i'ma tase you put you out
you know because somehow to rob my home
voice
or whatever and um
i'm in the often uh tase you
let you go down so they can come and see
who you is and we can all [ __ ] you
you know and it's like when this
happened
a week ago
i mean the guys that are out here
picking girls up
i mean they're they seem like they're
insane
they are yeah they are i mean maybe they
have mental problems too
maybe they have um low self-esteem too
um i don't i don't know what they're
going through that
probably the corona virus i don't know
you know what i'm saying
everybody getting greedy everybody out
there want to rob hoes
and uh um
mislead a [ __ ] but i feel like we
should all be in community if we in the
same game yeah no it seems to me i
i've mentioned this a lot in some of the
talks with the girls that work the
street
um it's just it seems evident that that
everyone's out for themselves the tricks
are right what they want the pimps want
what they want the girls are all like
in competition against each other right
everybody's
and it's like um like it it's
it's [ __ ] we struggling you know what
i'm saying
and we can't even come together and keep
a room together
you know like [ __ ] the magic carpet the
guy upstairs downstairs jacuzzi room
[ __ ] at least we have that
you know what i'm saying but it's not
that type of party no
more yeah it's a rough life they still
don't they still
even even the whole is stealing from
holes right now
and it's ridiculous you know
my knees went like this the last time
i'm saying i had a rough you know
i i i'm i'm just strong i'm acrobatic
and
i've been moving my way out of some [ __ ]
but
man you're a survivor
i got fresh wounds that ain't right you
know what i'm saying for dumb [ __ ]
you know and uh it's ridiculous out
there right now
right now you know i mean as of last
night
it's ridiculous you know if if i didn't
uh
maintain my regulars some of my regulars
or whatever because i didn't switch
phones like 90 going north because i'd
be around my
home partners and lose my phone or get
my phone stolen
that's what i mean ain't nobody out for
nobody why would you take my phone i
need my
you never know what i got to do i
had six phones stolen in the last past
three months
that ain't right yeah oh it's
dangerous gang [ __ ] i'm trying to call
christmas
and get me a job i don't give a damn
because this ain't it
you know i'm telling anybody that's
looking at this video this [ __ ]
ain't it
no i i'm surprised anybody gets into
this yeah but don't get me wrong it's
fun as [ __ ] at times
what what's the attraction for me
for anybody for all a lot of girls are
doing it i mean i mean but so many
different
uh point of views of attractions because
some i've noticed lately because my
daughter
um justin hit the whole stroll
how can i how can i say anything i i've
never raised her
yeah right but she
she's been on the whole show i've been
looking for her looking for her
the last time i think i shot the video i
think i was looking for my daughter i
think i mentioned that right so
um anyway she's been found yeah
you know she's whole yeah i'm saying she
holding 90 going north
how old is she you know she got a pimp
she's 16. you know we just had her 16th
birthday
you know but um i didn't know she was
doing the things that she's doing
however it made me get a different
outlook on this [ __ ] real quick
because it's a different even though i
never raised my baby
you know even though she was adopted to
my auntie and uncle
to see something that came from me
even though i didn't care then i care
now you know
i don't i don't want to be standing on
the [ __ ] corner
uh on long beach or western uh
figaro's in the 60s
and and see my daughter
that'll tell me that ain't gonna have
nothing that's liverpool
what what's the attraction but my
attract the attraction that she said is
for her
it's because she got you know what i'm
saying this [ __ ] to love her
that she think they love her because she
was just a gang member that's
that's figured out that you can wrestle
yourself like a pimp yeah
you know that's what they call a gorilla
pimping tennis shoe pimping yeah
they want to stand on your heels and all
that [ __ ] why why they do what they
do
why you do what you do i don't know how
the [ __ ] you can catch a date anyway
your mind ain't even cover steady you
can't even be a happy hoe they make dope
you know because you're too busy trying
to worry about you know
what time to go in how much to charge
you know because i i remember you know
i'm saying when i was working for a pm
you know i used to worry about you know
i'm saying that i called it the right
time
did i do this did i come in at the right
time did i make enough did i make my
whole quarter
you've had how many tips i have four i
had four parents before
i was a two's yeah you know i was saying
because it was everything right here i'm
going to the next
so the way a girl leaves one pimp and
goes to another is she chooses
oh she would have to and then does she
have to pay she would have to does she
have to pay her i would give [ __ ] if
it's that going point
you have to make the choice she would
have to choose but if you're leaving
one temp to go to another one you have
to make some transaction i mean [ __ ]
why wouldn't you well it probably
depends on the people if you want that
if you want that [ __ ] pen why
wouldn't you go that [ __ ]
oh no excuse me i got 2500 on me right
now i'm trying to choose your team
it ain't it ain't like that no more
though
how is it now it ain't like that that's
how it used to be
yeah you know what i'm saying that's
real [ __ ] pioneer
yeah it's not like that anymore we don't
even walk in the yellow the yellow brick
line no more i mean in the middle of the
street
we only walk the yellow brick line no
more we too big chasing running across
the street running this way loving the
line lighting all that [ __ ] and getting
[ __ ]
but are the girls free to leave now or
they're are they free to leave
yeah but just running i don't even know
how they there
they running too much they on their
phone too much
all right i mean [ __ ] you can't even
look at traffic because you're on your
phone with your opinion
you can't even pay attention to what the
[ __ ] you doing to get off of it
to get out of it cause you too busy
worried about
how he feel uh how you feel i
haven't seen so many [ __ ] walking
down the whole stroll with [ __ ]
friends on their face and all that
[ __ ]
in the last past month and a half it's
ridiculous
[ __ ] for the put a smile on your face
happy hoes make dough
i mean [ __ ] because if you if you mad at
him
because last night and it's last night
you can't get last night baby
come on into today
you know see it
it's like damn then as soon as i get up
mark
you know what i'm saying i'm that [ __ ]
to hide my money in the [ __ ]
hole on the ground
i don't give a damn because i don't know
who around me
yeah everybody else seems like they got
alien dna and they human humans were
eddie and dna
and drugs drugs are still a big part of
it i mean [ __ ] they can't be
but i don't smoke when i'm on the whole
stroll
number the nicotine cigarette
drink a sip a 211 steel reserve so i can
stay on the curve
you know what i'm saying i mean [ __ ]
somehow you got to be altercated i don't
give a damn
if you altercated to a dick through a
dick if you altercated through drugs
either you architected to alcohol either
you altercated to motivation
i wouldn't give a damn what you're going
to be articulating on something
your addiction gonna be something i
don't give a damn
even if it's making the next
[ __ ] feel good
because you don't know who you is yet
it's gotten to be more dangerous that
was that that was my major part that was
my major project
uh my problem is trying to satisfy the
next [ __ ] for what i ain't even
satisfied myself
you know i i used to be riding dick and
all that [ __ ] trying to get
[ __ ] off of [ __ ] [ __ ] she
forgot about you
but like a lot of the a lot of the
john's want to do it without a condom
now and i hear all
i mean it's a lot of them that want to
do it without a condom but it's ways
you know i had a couple of them pulled
over and said they want some head
okay without a comment okay i got you
don't worry about nothing because i put
my column on my mouth anyway
so how would you even know it's there
until it's done
you know what i'm saying yeah i mean it
it's hoes it ain't been school right
cause that john's they want to do
without a counter been going on way
back then and it ain't happened
you know the bushes that they doing
the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
deciding to do now is it's called
strawberrying
you know i'm saying cherry in it what's
that no
yeah [ __ ] mother
make sure you ready
my granny's just died from hiv my mama
suffering from hiv
why the [ __ ] not me
my name on the father anyway so i don't
have that problem
you know it's called being official with
whatever you do
do your best at whatever you do
have a goal for whatever the [ __ ] you do
because if you ain't doing it
with no purpose then what is it good for
absolutely nothing you know
last time i came home i i i had a roof
over my head right now i'm struggling
with no roof over my head
mobile home burned down i don't even
know how the mobile home get
burned down i haven't had a heart attack
since then you had a heart attack
yeah i'm saying stress to do that to you
drugs included
alcohol included you know i'm saying
experimental drugs included
experimental drugs when i say that i'm
like you know
what daddy sherm you know i'm saying all
that [ __ ]
and um christina you know i'm saying
them chemically made drugs
but herb keep me slow so i can't no way
anyways mark today i came to say
if you can't if you've been doing if if
i've been doing the same thing
this long and have been elevated
or every time i elevate i'll allow
somebody in
to to to shock on my feet or let me down
then i'm doing the wrong thing
i feel like now that i'm doing the same
thing and expecting different results
like i can
master this [ __ ]
i got 36 regulars i ain't master [ __ ]
you know about how to get the next paper
how to get the next bread how to get the
next doll
without a lie
without lying to get some [ __ ]
bread without stealing against
[ __ ] bread because i even look
over my back for nothing i'm not gonna
catch whiplash
whiplash ain't for me i'm not
if it's your money you can have it if
you give it to me then it's my money and
you ain't gonna get it back
but you know i just i don't second job
and i feel like this all you women out
there that's um
robbing these tricks and all that [ __ ]
just two weeks ago i suffered from it
i almost got dragged and killed
if i didn't let go the bumper that
[ __ ] car i'll be asked out
it ain't worth it but [ __ ] gonna
give it to you it ain't for you
are you little [ __ ] out there
that's trying to be
this [ __ ] right here look at the frowns
on the [ __ ] face
and you'll realize that it ain't for you
get another job
that's all i got to say mark
all right bonafide thank you so much for
coming in again
i wish you the best of luck darling this
is a hard time